foreign
combat games on video systems While
others prefer to exchange the controller
for a fake weapon dress up in costume
and act out the fantasy with those who
share the same passion it's called
live-action role-playing and there's
typically a medieval or apocalyptic
theme to it
these weapons sure look like the real
thing so much so that this company also
sells them as film and theater props
foreign
but as menacing as these axes and swords
appear they couldn't even hurt a fly
because their blades are made of latex
in the weapons Workshop they begin the
sword making process by constructing the
blade
after tracing a template on a four
tenths of an inch thick piece of
flexible waterproof foam they cut out
two blade halves with a utility knife
after slitting one of them down the
middle they glue in a rigid four tenths
of an inch thick fiberglass core this
makes the sword blade stiff enough for
combat yet flexible enough to not break
next they glue a strip of durable
polyester fabric over the core this acts
as reinforcement preventing the tip of
the core from poking through the foam
now they glue the second blade half over
the first one sandwiching the core
the glue is a rubber based adhesive that
bonds with pressure that they apply with
a heavy marble rolling pin
next using a band sander they sculpt the
Blade's cutting edges
foreign
then they've removed the foam residue
with a rotary tool
next they take a wood burning iron and
melt the foam and select spots to create
the look of Battle Scars
then they spray on five to six coats of
latex rubber this forms a protective
shield over the foam without hindering
the Blade's flexibility
next using an airbrush they apply two
coats of acrylic based latex paint first
black then silver
they brush on a thick coat of black
paint then wipe it off this wash as it's
called creates the look of aged metal
and finally they lightly dab some silver
acrylic paint over select spots to
highlight details
from foam to main component of a lethal
weapon in just a few easy steps
they finish off their handiwork by
stenciling on the company logo in gold
acrylic paint
now for the sword's handle they drill a
hole lengthwise through a cylinder made
of Walnut and glue a steel tube inside
then they glue leather around the wood
Apple leather ribbon around it for
decoration
to give it a worn appearance they
lightly sand parts of the surface
to make ornate handles an artist's first
sculpts a model out of Lindenwood
using that wooden model they cast a
silicon mold then they pour rubber into
the mold to cast a handle
for that leather covered wooden handle
they cast only the components above and
below it in rubber
after trimming off the excess rubber
they paint it to look like metal
to assemble the sword they glue the
handle components onto the core which
protrudes from the base of the blade
first they position the guard it stops
the opposing sword from sliding down
past the blade and cutting your hand
next the handle
and last the pommel it blocks the end of
the handle to prevent the sword from
sliding out of your hand
each sword this Workshop creates comes
with a Scabbard a protective leather
sheath they boil and wax the leather to
make it rigid
the workshop also makes daggers and
other realistic looking Weaponry all you
need to bring out your inner warrior
[Music]